कि नमस्कार जर्मन सीखिए हिंदी में के
स्पेशल एपिसोड में आपका स्वागत है यह
एपिसोड इंपोर्टेंट है कि इसमें हम सीखने
वाले हैं कि मैंने जो अब तक की वीडियो में
सब लोग हैं और उसके साथ किसी मेडिकल लिए
जर्मन कैसे सीख सकते हो और उसके रिलेटिड
जो बहुत सिर्फ डाइट से लोगों में उनके
आंसर देने की मैं कोशिश करूंगा तो शुरू
करते हैं तो सबसे पहला लोगों ने बहुत सारे
पूछा था कि हम लोग मनमुटाव था कि इसके साथ
ही वह वीडियोस है यह तो सब ठीक है अपने
ऑफिस वीडियो अपलोड की हैं पर क्लासेस तो
अलग होते हैं तो हम इन्हें साथ सीखेंगे
कैसे तो एक चीज मुझे पता नहीं है कि जो
वीडियो से वह बेहतर रैंडमली अपलोड नहीं
किए हैं मैंने अभी तक जो अपनी फ्लाइट
इसमें सीखा है उसका जो क्लॉक दिखाओ उसी
फ्लॉर से मैंने यह वीडियोस अपलोड की हैं
कि इन फैक्ट इन फैक्ट जब मैं क्लासेस
हुआ था कि हफ्ते में दो बार कि मतलब एकाध
मैच ट्यूसडे फ्राइडे होती थी दूसरी
वेनरेशन डैड हफ्ते में दो दिन तीन दिन का
गैप ट्रक के हमले देते हैं वैसे ही मेरे
वीडियोस के अपलोड किए थे अगर आपको याद हो
मैं वेनसडे और संडे को वीडियोस अ फॉलो
करता था तो अगर आपको इससे पढ़ना है तो
कैंसर की एक राजी कर रहे हो आप ऐप सिंपल
अटकी समझो कि आपने ग्लास लगाया है और एक
टाइम डिसाइड कर प्रॉमिस नहीं करोगे और फिर
जो भी आपका पहला दिन है उसमें एक
कंसेप्सियोन को नेक्स्ट टीम द नेक्स्ट तीन
दिन उस कंसेप्ट किया प्रीमियम करो आपको
देखना तो वीडियो पार फिर से देख सकते हो
नेक्स्ट टीम ने उस पर अपने-अपने 5 सेंटेंस
बनाओ फिर चौथे दिन नया कंसेप्ट लोग ऐसे
आपको हफ्ते में दो कंसेप्ट सीखने हैं
कि अगर आप ऐसे करते जाओगे तो Total 6
महीने में आप भवन तक पहुंच जाओगे सिंपल है
प्रिंट इस टेंपर्ड ग्लास तो उसको एक अगर
आप एक कप को पैटर्न दे दोगे ना तो आपको
इजी हो जाएगा एक दिन में चार-चार वीडियोस
देखना है से मत करो उससे आप उस टाइम समझ
में आएगा पर बाद में भूल जाओगे हफ्ते में
दो कंसेप्ट हर रोज पांच अपने सेंटेंसेस
क्लियर है दूसरा क्वेश्चन मुझे लोग बहुत
पूछते हैं कि वही आगे इंटरएक्टिव तो है
नहीं ना जो कुछ भी आप राशि तो इंटरएक्टिव
होते हैं तो पहली चीज अगर आप देखोगे तो
इसीलिए मैंने अपने वीडियोस एकदम
इंटरएक्टिव है से यह बताया कि जैसे सीख
जैसे लगे कि वे क्लास ले रहा हूं लोग बहुत
पर मैंने से पूछा है कि वह सिंपल है न समझ
में आया था ऐसे में जब बोलो हुआ इवन
वीडियोस में क्योंकि मैंने वैसे ही सिखाया
जैसे मैं अपने क्लासेस में सीखा था अनदर
क्वेश्चन इसकी भी हमारे डाउट्स का किया तो
उसके लिए अपने पास एडमिन्यूज है एक तो आप
कमेंट सेक्शन में आपके आउटपुट सकते हो FD
जिम में
लिया है उस पर अपने क्वेश्चसं पूछ सकते हो
मैं विदीन टू डेज आपके हर डोंट का आंसर
देने की हमेशा कोशिश करता हूं अगर कोई
इंपोर्टेंट है कोई कंसेप्ट अलग है तो वह
महीने के हर पहले और तीसरे बुधवार पहले और
तीसरे वेंसले मैं लाइव आता हूं तब मैं
आपके वजन क्वेश्चन आंसर दे सकता हूं तो
अगर आपके डाउट क्लियर करना इशू है तो
हमारे लिए उसके बाद उसके लिए हमारे पास
उसका भी रेवेन्यू है और एक लोगों के मन
में होता है कि घूमना है अभी वह मटका कैसे
पता है ना कि आई डोंट बिलीव इन द कंसेप्ट
फोन हुआ है अगर आपको मन से सीखना है तो इस
वेरी सिंपल और क्या कर रहा है मेरे जो
मैथिल है कि जॉब कंसेप्सियोन उस पर 5
सेंटेंस बनाओ सपोच मतलब पहला यह वीडियो
आपको याद होगा तो उसमें क्या सिखाता है कि
वह सिंपल सेंटेंस बनाना है इसको म इस
अश्लील तो आज 5 सेंटेंस बनाओ दूसरे दिन नए
पांच वकीलों और पथक-पथ सेंट्रल फिर अपने
कहती सीखा तो अपना नाम का स्पेलिंग
अपने फ्रेंड के नाम का वॉल्व अपने गांव के
नाम का बोलो उसके बाद नंबर सी के तो मैं
उसका आपको ट्रिक यह घड़ी देखो जिस जब
तुमको टाइम जीके टाइम टाइम बोलो डेटशीट
फिर जब आप मोड व पर जाओगे तो आपको ओरिजिनल
आपको देखो आपने पहले पीलन स्पीलर क्रिकेट
थोड़ा हार्ड लगा होगा पंजाब मोड और मैं
आगे इसका क्रिकेट पीलन करोगे तो आपको याद
आएगा और ऐसे कितने सेंटेंस बना सकते
डायबटीज पेशंट कुछ भी बना सकते हो उसके
लिए किसी ने दूसरे ने आपको मोड व के लिए
वह सेंटेंस देने की जरूरत नहीं है और
जैसे-जैसे आगे जाओगे जिसमें स्पीड संता
बोला पहले स्पिनर अवार्ड लगेगा पर एक बार
इसमें किया फिर एक बार सपोच आ क्वेश्चन
में फीसदी क्रिकेट आया है तो इतनी बार आप
तोड़ो क्रिस्पी लर्न मतलब खेलने आपका हो
ही जाएगा समझ रहे हो तो इसीलिए इस ऐप को
जब आप फर्स्ट में तो जो का जो अ होता है
वह बहुत हार्ड लगता है वही फोर्थ पर यह तो
यह लगने लगता है वैसे ही हो जाएगा तो डोंट
वरी अपने-अपने
कि रोज पांच ने सेंटर्स अट सेट इतना ही
आपके लिए काफी है अभी पहुंचे झट बहुत सारे
लोगों को गुस्सा है गर्ल्स वेरी कॉमन
क्वेश्चन कि यह वीडियोस काफी है क्या कि
वह इन वीडियोस के साथ में एवरेज b1 कर
सकता हूं क्या तो इसका आंसर में ऐसे दूंगा
कि यह मेथड काफी है मतलब इस मेथड से कि वह
यह जो 4556 वीडियोस में मैंने जो सिखाया
है वह सी के और हर रोज अपने 5 सेंटेंस
बनाकर मेरे बहुत सारे स्टूडेंट्स को एक
1821 में बहुत अच्छे अच्छा सेक्टर्स मिला
है तो इट वर्ग समझ रहे हो न तो यह सिद्ध
क्वालिटी आफ थे वीडियोस इन अ बोट
इंपोर्टेंट कि इसमें सेल्फ स्टडी आपने हर
रोज अपने
सेंटेंस बन
और इस वीडियोस देखने से नहीं होगा पर यह
अगर आप इसमें इधर से जाते हो वीडियो देखो
उस पर 5 सेंटेंस हर रोज अपने बनाओ सेल्फ
स्टडी करो ऐसे अगर आप करके गए तो
डेफिनेटली यह वीडियो की क्वालिटी में कोई
ढाल लेने की जरूरत नहीं है ओके तो नेक्स्ट
क्वेश्चन उससे बैटर और आई थिंक उसका आंसर
है ना बहुत जरूरी है अगर यह वीडियो इतने
अच्छे अर्थशास्त्री क्यों है अल्लाह आप
इसको चार्ज क्यों नहीं करते क्योंकि आजकल
इतना कमर्शलाइजेशन हो गया है एजुकेशन का
के लोगों को ऐसे लगता कि कोई चीज बड़ी है
तो मतलब इनफीरियर होगी तो समझ लें कि हर
किसी का एक एग होता है लाइफ में तो मेरा
एक गेम है कि जिसको जर्मन सीखनी है उसको
सीखनी मिलनी चाहिए क्रीम अभी तक जिसके पास
रिसोर्ट से एक है जो मेट्रो में रहता है
या फिर जो क्लासेस लगा सकता है वह थे में
जाकर या और कहीं भी क्लास लगा कि जर्मन
सीख सकता है पर जिसके पास यह रिसोर्सेस
अवेलेबल नहीं है उसको भी जर्मन सीखने को
मिले यह मेरा देश है और इसीलिए यह करना तो
मैं जब मैं एक्चुअली क्लासेज भी लेता
ऑनलाइन तो भी मैं उस वक्त लेता था मैंने
आज तक जर्मन सिखाने से ₹1 भी नहीं कमाया
है और इसीलिए तो अगर आपके मन में कोई डाउट
है तो वह भी निकाल दो कि वह आप यहां पर
थोड़ा कम लेवल का सिखाता है दूसरे कहां
ज्यादा सिखाता है जो मुझे आता है वह मैंने
वीडियोस में सिखाया है विद हाईएस्ट
क्वालिटी आपको समरी में ऐसे बोल सकता हूं
कि मैं हर किसी को ऐसा लगता है कि मैं
सोसाइटी को हमने कुछ तो वापस देना चाहिए
तो इन दिस इज माय वे गिव बैक की महीना
मेरे लिए सब सोसायटी ने किया तो वह उसका
जो पेस्ट है वह करने की यह मेरी कोशिश है
से आप समझ सकते हो तो प्लीज डोंट थिंग की
बाबा यह फ्री है तो इसकी क्वालिटी कैसे
होगी तो नेक्स्ट क्वेश्चन पर आते हैं
नेक्स्ट होता है कि वह हम प्रैक्टिस कैसे
करें ओके तो अ सबसे पहले से लोगों के वह
अभिनेत्री कैसे पड़ा है तो सबसे पहले चीज
हमारी वीडियो ही में अगर आप देखोगे तो एक
तो हमारा 250 वर्ष का एक पुत्र एपिसोड है
टोटल अगर आपने यह थी
कि यह तो फोर्सेज आपके हो जाएंगे और अगर
आपको आपके वो की अवधि बढ़ानी है आगे ने
कंसिस्टेंसी जिंदगी रोज पांच वह रोज 5
मिनट बाद एक ही नोट बुक रखो कि आज कपल्स
आपको पीस लेना है transportation तंग
कोटेशन फॉर ट्रांसपोर्टेशन थीम लोग और
पिछड़ों तुम्हें बस को क्या बोलते ट्रेन
को क्या बोलते हैं Aeroplane को क्या
बोलते हैं कार को क्या बोलते साइकिल को
क्या बोलते होंगे आपके पास वर्ल्ड और अगर
पॉसिबल को कि सेंटेंस बनाओ नहीं है तो
वर्ल्ड केवल लिखो हर रोज पांच वर्ड्स आप
सीखोगे तो 6 महीने में यू विल अर्न मोर थन
वर्ड्स और यह 500 है थोडा सा बहुत अच्छी
मुकाबले होती है शोल्डर डोंट वरी अबाउट
वोकैबलरी मुकाबले की बजाय में एक दिन में
50 अवार्ड याद करूंगा को याद नहीं रहने
वाले और कंटेंट के साथ नहीं याद रखोगे तो
वह भूल जाते हैं तो डोंट वरी अबाउट दैट हर
रोज अपने अपने कंटेंट से पांच नहीं और
सीखने ठीक है दूसरी चीज होती कि लहसुन और
यूरिन की प्रैक्टिस कैसे करें
अपने की ओर सुनने की तो उसके लिए मैं
बोलता हूं जब जब मैं पढ़ रहा था वह साल
पहले तब तो बहुत कम रिसोर्सेज से आजकल
इंटरनेट के इस प्रोजेक्ट के साथ देर सो
मिनी रिसोर्सेज़ मेरा फेवरेट डॉयचे वेल
डॉयचे वेले की वेब साईट और YouTube चैनल
इन पर आपको इतना जटिल मिलेगा क्या आप थक
जाओगे तरह टैरिफ ख़त्म नहीं होगा प्रिंस
चम्मच मतलब आप जो अब देख सकते हो वहां पर
जाकर आप सेवन लेवल से लेकर आप भी वनप्लस
तक भी हो जो अब जितना चाहिए उतना मटेरियल
आपको अवेलेबल है अगर आपको चाहिए तो बहुत
सारे और वेबसाइट भी हैं आइए हम इसी टॉपिक
पैदा और यह बात कर लेते हैं कि लोग मुझे
पूछते कि मैं कौन सा बुक यूज करूं क्या
तुम मेरी जो मेथड है मेरी एक हर किसी के
एक मैटर होती है मेरी नजर में तो वह बुक
जरूरी नहीं है सब मैं समझता हूं कि वह जो
मैं सिखा रहा हूं वह अगर आप ठीक से समझ लो
और अपने-अपने हर रोज पांच कंटेंस बनाओ तो
वह काफी है अगर आपको यूज करते हैं तो आपको
बहुत सारे
ए पब्लिकेशन के बहुत सारे बुक है आप यूज
कर सकते हो मैं ओनली कंसर्न इसकी बहुत बार
क्या होता है वह भूख जर्मन * जर्मन होते
हैं और उसके कारण लोग थोड़ा टेंस ओके
डिमोरलाइज हो जाते हैं उतना निकट होने मन
तो उसके बाद अब जो करना है करो आपको जो ऐप
चाहिए वह यूज करो ड्यूरिंग और आप यूज
करेंगे किसी बात पर डायरेक्टर नहीं रुका
जो चाहिए वह एप्स AC को इतने सारे वेबसाइट
है इतने सारे यूट्यूब चैनल है जहां से
सीखना है सीखो कि वह हमें क्या है कला कुछ
इतने लेवल की जर्मन आती थी उससे थोड़ी
ज्यादा आ जानी चाहिए फिर वह किस में इधर
से आती है हमको कुछ फर्क नहीं पड़ता स्वयं
मटेरियल जो आप यूज करो अच्छा है बट इनका
क्रंच जो मैं रख लो है अगर मेरी मैं छोड़
फ्लॉप फ्लॉप फ्लॉप करोगे तो यूं मिले
क्रिकेट सबसे लोकप्रिय हो गया लेजर और
ह्यूमर उसके बाद आता है श्रवण तो हम हर
रोज 500 सेंटेंस लिखने की प्रैक्टिस कर है
और फिर आता है स्पेशल बहुत सारे लोग बोलते
फिर मुझे बोलना ही नहीं आता तो बोलना कब
आएगा जब
लोग इन्हें तो जो आपके होंठ लेवल को होना
तो अपने छोटे सेंटेंस बनाओ
कि मैं रिक्वेस्ट है कि वह मैं यह खाना
चाहता हूं तो इसमें एडिसन इतने छोटे-छोटे
सेंटेंस बनाते जाओ अब मन में बोलते जाओ
मेरठ के साथ बोलते जाओ आप अगर अगर आपका जब
ए टू खत्म होने को आता है आप भी वन शुरू
कर रहे हो और अगर आपको पार्टनर नहीं मिल
रहा है ट्राइड टो गेट कि तुम्हारा कोई
एप्पल फ्रेंड तुम्हारे साथ सीख रहा है
क्या अगर नहीं मिल रहा है तो मुझे ईमेल ID
से ईमेल करो मैं आपको पार्टनर ढूंढ कर
देने की कोशिश करूंगा बट ट्रस्ट मे मुझे
इसका बहुत अच्छा एक्सपीरियंस नहीं है लोग
एवं जोश में आकर नाम दे देते हैं और फिर
जब बोलना शुरू होता है तो फिर वह आते नहीं
है बोलने को अंतर्गत दर्द प्रॉब्लम
हिस्ट्री तो पार्टनर तो आकर ऑफ कमिटेड हो
कि मौका नहीं अभी मुझे जर्मन बोलना सीखना
है अगर आपको लगता है कि आप भवन लेवल पर
पहुंच गए हो तो ही मुझे ईमेल करो आई विल
ट्राइ माइ बेस्ट टो गिव पार्टनर और फाइनली
एक्जाम रिलेटेड बहुत सारे लोगों को एकदम
रिलेटेड क्वेश्चन सोते हैं तो उसके लिए
मैंने ऑलरेडी वीडियोस बनाए हैं उसकी एक
युक्ति बनाई है अब जाकर व प्लेलिस्ट देख
सकते हो कि डोंट क्लियर हो जाएंगे इन
फैक्ट जब अब ऐसे बहुत सारी प्लेलिस्ट
मैंने बनाए हैं कि अगर केस है कट
कंजंक्शंस है एग्जाम की प्ले लिस्ट मैंने
बनाई है चेहरों को रिवीजन करनी है तो अब
जाकर वह प्ले लिस्ट भी देख सकते हो तो
मुझे आशा है कि अभी आपको समझ में आया होगा
कि मेरे वीडियोस के साथ आप कैसे जर्मन सीख
सकते हो और आपके सारे डाउट क्लियर हुए
होंगे अगर नहीं हुए हैं तो आप कमेंट में
क्वेश्चन लिख सकते हो या फिर आप मुझे ईमेल
कर सकते हो यह ऑलवेज अधेरे टो क्लियर योर
डाउट्स धन्यवाद अ